hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game from the final round of
this year's London chess classic it is
Hans nean versus GES and GES uh needs a
win uh not just win in this game he
needs to win this tournament in order to
qualify for the FED candidates
tournament but it's not enough to win
this final game against Hans he also has
to uh wait to see how the game between
Michael Adams who's been having an
incredible tournament will finish
against Shas Royale and Shas is the
bottom seat of the tournament he's an
international master H but even though
he defeated tabatabai and Jil musard so
anything could happen and he does have
the white pieces against Adam so best
thing gkes can hope for H is that you
know K kaisa Smiles upon him on this day
and that he he wins and qualifies for
the candidates tournament but let's see
what happened in this game as he faces a
most UN unpleasant opponent that is Hans
Neeman so Hans has the wi pieces and he
opens with E4 uh E5 by gkes Knight F3
Knight to C6 and Bishop to C four we
have Bishop to C5 countering the Italian
game with the Joko piano and now Pawn to
D3 already deviating from the main line
we have Knight to F6 castles and pawn to
D6 so very standard stuff we see this
pretty much in every other game that we
cover C3 and we have A6 and A4 uh we
have Bishop to A7 so we don't have to
worry about any any pawns challenging
that Bishop in the future with B4 or D4
Rook to E1 and now Pawn to H6 you guys
already know what happens if you go
after the pawn on F2 I'm sure I don't
have to repeat that anymore uh grabbing
more space on the queen Side Pawn A5 and
now Pawn to G5 Gish says that he wants
to go for the attack he's ready to go G4
and it's up to Hans to figure out a
defense against this we have Bishop to
E3 cing guer strong Bishop on A7 and now
there are a few games where Bishop
captures on E3 was played but here guer
goes for the immediate G4 and it is now
as of move 10 that we have a completely
new game H okay we have Knight F to D2
have to move the Knight and now Bishop
captures on E3 and H says all right I
could capture with the Rook but let's
make it interesting F captures on E3 uh
we have Knight to H7 and now uh Knight
to F1 a standard squares for the Knight
the Knight of course is coming to G3 and
then later on to F5 we have Pawn to H5
and now Knight to G3 and this also uh
not not just uh uh prepares Knight F5
but also stops any F5 ideas black might
have so here we have Queen to G5 it's a
sure way of stopping Knight to F5 and
also you put pressure on the E3 Pawn so
you don't have to worry about the Rook
being shifted to F1 as that F7 Pawn
could come under attack so here Knight
to D2 and now Knight to E7 adding more
support to the uh F5 square and also
preparing Central advancement with C6
and D5 uh Knight E7 is met with Queen to
A4 with check C6 and now Queen to B4 uh
sort of hindering the development of the
light Square Bishop uh but uh not for
long H4 challenges the Knight Knight to
F5 and now Bishop captures an F5 we have
e captures an F5 and now Gish first
grabs more space in the center Pawn to
D5 Bishop back to B3 and now Gish
castles King side and this is a clear
attempt at playing for a win here H
because if you want to draw here you
will just Castle Queen side now the
point is that after Bishop to D1 going
after this G4 Pawn you don't really have
a good way of dealing with this Knight
captures and F5 will be played Queen
captures and G four and queens have to
now come off the board because E4 is
coming so that's a problem for black and
with Queens off the board it's a air
fairly equal position but after Bishop
to B3 I imagine as this is the final
round and gkes really needs a win to
qualify for the candidat tournament if
at all possible he castles King's side
and he says uh you know what'll be will
be and now uh there is only one move uh
that he missed probably uh uh maybe he
considered but may maybe he just didn't
think it was that powerful but there is
one mood that Hans can play at that just
wins the game on the spot for for him so
feel free to pause the video and try to
figure it out and then we will see if
Hans found it over the board uh have at
it so uh for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations on being a true
master of positional play and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is Queen Capt on I'm only kidding it
is of course Rook to A4 Rook to A4 is
move and now once you see this move you
realize that uh there's really no good
move uh that black can make here and
what I mean by this is what if white
just goes for Bishop to D1 the move that
we covered in the outer line is it any
good here it's good but it's nothing
special black will capture on F5 and
after Queen captures and G4 Queen
captures and Bishop captures he will
simply move the Knight and the game
continues nothing spectacular happening
here however after Rook the A4 uh you
have so many weaknesses on the fourth
Rank and there's no good way of dealing
with this now Knight captures on F5 is
easily met with Queen captures on G4 and
once Queens get traded let's see
captures captures with check King h8 E4
right away uh pretty much seals the deal
you have a weakness on D5 you're going
to lose that pawn once you move the
Knight you're going to lose the H4 Pawn
as well then the other Rook joins the
attack or if you try something like
let's say the captures on e4 uh even
Rook captures on e4 now this is a
weakness this is a weakness um there's
really not all that much you can do here
uh so you will start losing material and
the open and soon to be open H file will
be you know a happy hunter hunting
ground for the for the white Rooks so
that's why after Rook to A4 Gish played
Pawn to G3 trying to get some sort of an
attack going but it doesn't help Queen
captures an H4 Queen captures Rook
captures an H4 he captures on H2 with
check Rook captures on H2 and now he
plays Pawn to F6 and this is a uh clear
indicator that something has gone
terribly wrong because if you could
capture on F5 then you would be okay but
look at this E4 and now if D captures on
e4 you will play Rook captures on e4
again this is a problem and now if you
defended Rook 8 to E8 now Rook to G4
with check King to h8 and Knight comes
to E4 uh next Knight is coming to G5 you
will not be able to defend anything here
if you play something like F6 even Rook
to H3 and black is without a move there
there there's no move you can make here
like you play Rook D7 Knight captures on
F6 and if you move it then Rook to G8 is
Checkmate as you forgot about our good
friend Bishop on B3 guarding the G8
Square so here there's really there's
there's no move this is a this is a t
Swang so after Rook captures an H2 uh
Gish had to defend he played Pawn to F6
but still Pawn to E4 just making use of
this excellent pin here uh and now we
have Rook to F7 uh better to be active
than to try and defend the D5 Pawn
Knight to F3 hunts even wants to play D4
to completely obliterate the position
Rook to G7 and now Pawn to D4 at e
captur on D4 Knight captures on D4 and
now once the Knight comes to E6 that's
pretty much it Knight to sorry Knight to
G5 was played uh e captures on D5 Knight
captures on D5 and now Rook to H6
putting more pressure on the pawn here
so C4 will H win the pawn so King to F7
defending this pawn and now King to F1
uh you have to be a little bit careful
because if you move the Knight Knight to
F3 check will sort of um win you win you
the exchange so better make sure this
doesn't happen King to F1 was played
Rook eight to G8 doubling up here hoping
to get some action along the G file now
c4 we have Knight to C7 C5 with check
improving the position as much as
possible uh before going for the capture
Bishop captures on D5 C captures Knight
to E6 and he was in this position un
move 35 that gkes resigned the game is
there is nothing more to be done here
The Rook will fall and once you lose the
The Exchange as well there's nothing to
be done here of course if you capture
the Knight that doesn't help just Rog
captures goes after the pawn and yes you
can capture here uh but it only means
you will lose that Rook because after
captures the King has to go to the G
file and now it's a free rook or if you
don't do that after Knight D6 um there's
no move you can play uh The Rook is just
hanging here if you try something like
this then Knight captur on G5 comes with
check so you lose the defender of The
Rook once you capture it again Gish will
be down a full Rook so uh very nicely
done by both of them gash played a very
active game he played that novelty G4
line uh but he completely missed hans's
Rook to A4 idea Hans found it and that's
all there is to this game so that's the
Joko piano uh you know it's a it's a
very cool opening white is very tricky
you know just waiting for black to go
for the attack and then if you're
careless then uh something like this uh
can easily take take the game away from
you uh what does this mean for gkes uh
well he did not qu qualify for the
candidates tournament via the fiday
circuit but it is not the end of the
road for him because out of nowhere uh a
tournament appears that that starts in
four days this tournament is of course
the Chennai Grand Masters
2023 and it will feature eight very very
strong players the tournament will be
led by param makulu world number 12 at a
rating of 2742 who also still has a
chance to qualify for the candidates
tournament VR rating if he does really
well in the tournament and the other
players who are still in contention for
the fedia circuit are arjuni the second
seed of the tournament at a rating of
2727 and gkes world number 28 at a
rating of 2720 so basically either
paraha makulu does really well and he
qualifies via rating or Arjun and gkes
have to win the tournament and then one
of them qualifies for the FED candidates
tournament so still I don't know it it
seems like everything is happening all
at once seems like new uh new possibil
abilities of qualifying emerge you know
out of nowhere uh so this might not be
the end of the road who knows we'll see
what happens but yeah that's some some
extra info yeah other players Leon Aran
of course San suugo Hari Krishna panov
and the the excellent Alexander prka
who's been playing some incredible chess
um lately so it's going to be fun we
still have no idea who will be in the
candidates tournament but whoever
qualifies will be will be a fine
addition to the already qualified six
yeah that's the game and a little extra
info on the canat tournament the Michael
the the Michael the tournament Was Won
very nicely by Michael Adam he just
dominated the entire event okay some of
you said that some of the points have
been gifted to him but you try playing
against Grand Masters At This level and
see if they gift you any points they
gifted points because he put pressure on
them and uh they had to you know uh
suffer through some difficult
possessions and at some point you will
blunder it's not like uh you know they
they GI you a point so I really don't
like comments like that uh but yeah
Michael Adams just spectacular event
finishes half a point um S I just don't
want to trick you guys uh finishes half
a point against Amin tabatabai and gkes
with five out of nine in third place so
yeah great event by by Michael Adams but
we will still have to see if gkes Will
qualify for the candidates tournament so
yeah once again hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank David gasparian
Albert Albert vardell Nathan I love that
Milos kovich and treats for Meo for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos s
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World uh thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day